nuestro primer contacto con el concepto
de la pendiente de una línea normalmente
ocurre a inicios de los cursos de
álgebra y aquí vamos a recordar un poco
de esto dibujamos nuestro eje este es
nuestro eje de las 10 o debería decir
nuestro eje de fx y ahora voy a dibujar
mi eje de las x aquí está
mi eje x
y ahora voy a dibujar una línea más o
menos así y lo que queremos hacer es
acordarnos de cómo calcular la pendiente
de una línea entonces como encontramos
la pendiente y lo que hacemos es tomar
dos puntos de esta misma línea vamos a
poner aquí un punto en otro color y
digamos que en el eje x va a tener el
valor de a y en el eje y va a ser el
valor cda y podemos decir que la función
es la función de una línea por ejemplo
que fx es igual a m por x + b no sabemos
que son m y b pero bueno esta es una
revisión de los conceptos así que aquí
tenemos en x el valorada y en que
tenemos que pasa con ese valor a cuando
lo utilizamos en la función definida
aquí y ahora tomamos otro punto en esta
línea aquí es b en x y la coordenada de
este punto aquí es
y coma efe db ya que este es el punto
donde evaluamos esta función en vez así
que dibujamos una línea aquí para poner
en eje y efe dv
y para que quede más claro pongo que en
este punto es la coordenada
efe
así que como encontramos la pendiente
entre estos dos puntos o en general es
la pendiente de toda esta línea ya que
recordemos que la pendiente va a ser
consistente en todo a lo largo de esta
línea también recordamos que una vez que
encontramos la pendiente pues va a ser
la pendiente de toda esta línea
recordamos es sólo una revisión sobre
álgebra pero como lo hacemos y definimos
la pendiente que es igual al crecimiento
entre cuanto avanza
y otra manera de escribirlo es el cambio
en y entre el cambio en x
ahora vamos a calcular cuál es el cambio
en y cuál es el cambio en x al menos
para este caso en particular así que el
cambio en g es igual a qué
bueno vamos a tomar las coordenadas de
estos dos puntos al menos en la parte
que corresponde allí tomando el que
tiene una yema es grande en este caso
debería ser ve el cambio
entre estos dos puntos voy a dibujar
este pequeño triángulo
esto de aquí es el cambio en y también
lo puedo proyectar en el eje y para que
se vea que el cambio en cuál es esta
distancia va a ser efe vm no se cede a
lo escribimos
efe db - efe dea y este es nuestro
cambio en g
así que efe db - efe aquí está nuestro
cambio en y ahora cuál es nuestro cambio
en x cambio en g / cambio en x
cuál es el cambio x vamos a tomar este
como nuestro primer punto ya que para
calcular la diferencia en usamos este
como el primer punto y así vamos a hacer
consistentes así que la parte x de este
punto menos la x de este otro punto en
este caso va a ser de menos
ve - ah y si tuviéramos la ecuación de
esta función podríamos calcular esos
puntos y entonces ya podríamos tener la
pendiente para esta línea y así de
directas como calculamos nuestra
pendiente y para asegurarnos de que esto
se entiende bien vamos a hacer un
ejemplo concreto vamos a decir que este
punto de aquí este que estoy señalando
tiene las coordenadas 2 3
y este otro que esto es color en
amarillo tiene las coordenadas 57
y ahora vamos a encontrar la pendiente
de esta línea sustituyendo estos valores
7 menos 3
que es nuestro cambio en ya que es este
7 aquí es 3 y esto lo vamos a dividir en
35 menos 2
este es nuestro cambio mx y aquí está el
5 y aquí está el 2 y este es nuestro
cambio
5 - 27 menos 3 64 entre 52 es 34 tercios
esta va a ser la pendiente de esta línea
que estamos especificando ahora veamos
si podemos generalizar esto y este va a
ser el nuevo concepto que vamos a
aprender aquí como una forma de
introducirnos al cálculo vamos a
generalizar esto a alguna curva así que
digamos que ahora tengo una curva y esta
curva de hecho lo voy a dibujar aquí en
junto para que puedan ver las
similitudes entre ambas
digamos que aquí tengo mis ejes
y en estos ejes voy a dibujar una curva
y digamos que esta curva es más o menos
conocida que igual a x cuadrada que luce
más o menos así
y lo que quiero hacer es encontrar su
pendiente en cualquier punto incluso
antes de hablar de esto vamos a pensar
en qué significa encontrar la pendiente
de una curva en este primer ejemplo la
pendiente fue la misma a todo lo largo
de esta función de esta línea pero no la
curva la pendiente va cambiando y para
tener una idea de lo que esto significa
la pendiente en este punto sería más o
menos esto la tangente a este punto de
la curva
y la pendiente sería esto y en este otro
punto la pendiente estaría así un
poquito menos negativa que la pendiente
anterior y de hecho bueno creo que voy a
ponerle en otro color para que se note
mejor la diferencia aquí la pendiente es
un poco menos negativa en cambio aquí en
este punto cero
la pendiente de esta plana
esta línea horizontal va a ser la
pendiente en este punto cuando las
funciones igual a cero y conforme vamos
avanzando en esta curva la pendiente
comienza a ser positiva y empieza a
incrementarse aquí está aún nada
pendiente y aquí está otra que tiene la
pendiente todavía más grande y como
pueden ver la pendiente está cambiando
en todos los puntos de esta curva y esa
es la diferencia entre la pendiente en
una línea y en una curva en una línea la
pendiente es constante y en una curva la
pendiente va cambiando en cambio en una
línea si toman dos puntos miren la
diferencia en x y la diferencia en ye y
divide en la diferencia y niek entre la
diferencia en xy ya obtuvieron la
pendiente de toda la línea y como vimos
aquí en la pendiente en una curva cambia
todo el tiempo si midiéramos la
pendiente acá sería todavía aún más alta
así que vamos a tratar de hacer un
experimento y como ya sé cómo resulta
este experimento no nos arriesgaremos
demasiado así que bueno voy a dibujar
algo aquí
mi eje y que lo puedo dibujar mejor aquí
está mi eje
y aquí dibujo mi eje x x
y aquí lo podemos llamar o fx de
cualquier manera es lo mismo
y aquí voy a dibujar mi curva
vamos a dibujar además la parte positiva
así
y que está si yo quisiera encontrar la
pendiente si yo quisiera encontrar la
pendiente aquí
con base a la definición de la pendiente
necesitaríamos dos puntos aquí no
sabemos cómo definir la pendiente con un
solo punto
vamos a llamar a este punto que acabo de
dibujar x
x para ponerlo en términos generales
para definir la pendiente de acuerdo con
nuestra definición básica de álgebra
necesitamos dos puntos así que vamos a
encontrar otro punto aquí vamos a
ponerlo en otro color vamos a tomar un
punto un poquito más grande que x que
bueno yo creo que vamos a poner un
poquito más alejados y no va a estar
todo muy atiborrado digamos que tengo
este punto de aquí y que este punto es
más grande que x y es más grande por una
cantidad h vamos a escribir aquí x más h
y eso es lo que es este punto y cuáles
serán sus valores correspondientes en el
eje y bueno esta es la curva de igual a
fx
este punto de aquí va a ser f de x de
nuestra particular x de acá que bueno
para hacerlo más claro esta x particular
la voy a llamar x de 0 esta de acá va a
ser x 0 + h por lo tanto en el eje 10
será fx de cero y la coordenada de este
otro punto
estará más o menos por acá
y le corresponde en el eje h
el punto f de x 0 h
y ahora cuál será la pendiente entre
estos dos puntos que están relativamente
cercanos recuerden que no va a ser la
pendiente solo en este punto va a ser la
pendiente de la línea que une estos dos
puntos y si yo la fuera a dibujar se
vería más o menos así una línea que
intersecta la curva tanto en este punto
como en este otro punto
vamos a dibujar un poquito más claro
aquí sería más o menos así como la
interfecta en este punto con nuestra
coordenada x 0 fd x 0 y aquí arriba que
sería nuestra coordenada x de 0 + h xy 0
+ h coma efe de x 0 + h
así que cualquiera que sea esta función
la estamos evaluando en estas
coordenadas y aquí tenemos estos dos
puntos una buena forma de comenzar es
encontrar la pendiente de esta línea
secante y como hicimos en el ejemplo
anterior
tenemos que encontrar el cambio mx y el
cambio pero este es el cambio en g
la vertical y dividirla entre nuestro
cambio en x que es la horizontal aquí
está de nuevo el cambio y el cambio en x
la pendiente de esta línea secante va a
ser igual a este punto de aquí que
parece ser un poco más grande así que
nuestro cambio en y que es este punto de
aquí va a ser
efe de x 0 más h y es este punto de que
aunque podría parecer algo más
sofisticado pero realmente lo que es es
este punto evaluado en el eje y de la
función n ese valor de x y esto va a ser
entonces el cambio de g efe x 0 + h la
coordenada de esto menos la coordenada n
del punto x en esta parte de aquí va a
ser efe x 0 y este es nuestro cambio en
g esto es nuestro cambio en g
y la dividimos entre el cambio en x cuál
es el cambio en x bueno tomamos el valor
más grande de x que es el de este punto
aquí x 0 + h - la coordenada xx que es x
0 x 0 así que esto es un cambio de eje
entre cambio de x pero bueno esta es la
pendiente de la línea secante pero
todavía no encontramos cuál es la
pendiente justo en este punto pero sin
duda esto nos va a ayudar a llegar a esa
respuesta vamos a simplificar esto así
que voy a escribir aquí la pendiente de
la línea secante de la línea secante es
igual a el valor de la función en este
punto
efe x 0 + h menos el valor de la función
aquí
efe de x0 que esto es el cambio en el
eje ye y es exactamente la misma
definición de pendiente que vimos al
principio entre el cambio en x que es
esta parte x 0 y aquí tenemos menos x0
estos dos se cancelan y nos queda
solamente h así que esto es igual a
nuestro cambio en g entre el cambio en x
muy bien pero quedamos que queremos
encontrar la pendiente en este punto de
la curva y que es lo que puedo hacer
bueno yo definí que este otro punto de
acá era el primer punto más una
distancia h esta h y tenemos algo en
nuestra caja de herramientas que se
llama límite ya que está h es un número
en general podría ser un 10 12
un número pequeño totalmente arbitrario
así que qué pasaría al menos en teoría
si yo comienzo a hacer esta h cada vez
más pequeña
si yo tomara el límite conforme h se
aproxima a cero imaginemos que al
principio hs este número grande de aquí
y si voy reduciendo h
más o menos por acá está pendiente va a
ser diferente y si sigo siendo más
pequeña h me voy a ir acercando la
pendiente de este punto si así fuera
tremendamente chiquitito estaríamos casi
encontrando la pendiente en el punto de
interés por supuesto que si esta h es
muy grande mi línea secante va a estar
muy lejana en comparación de la
pendiente que me interesa en este punto
pero si está h fuera un número
infinitamente pequeño entonces me
quedaría bastante a la pendiente que me
interesa así que qué pasa si yo tomo el
límite de esto conforme h se aproxima a
cero el límite cuando h tiende a cero
la pendiente de mi secante
efe de x 0 + h - efe x 0
/ h que es mi cambio es en x que es h a
veces en lugar de la h se escribe delta
x así que en lugar del límite cuando h
tiene 0 sería cuando delta x tiende a
cero y aquí bueno sustituimos las h por
delta equis y quedaría exactamente lo
mismo no importa si es h o delta x lo
que estamos usando es la diferencia
entre un punto equis y el punto x mayor
y si tomamos el límite de esto cuando se
aproxima a cero encontraremos esta delta
equis y ahora voy a llamar a esto que es
igual a la pendiente de mi línea
tangente a mi punto de interés esto es
igual a la pendiente de la línea
tangente en un punto de esta curva esto
lo voy a llamar la derivada de f
derivada
efe y voy a decir que esto es igual
efe prima de equis y esta va a ser otra
función recordemos que la pendiente
cambia en cada valor de x no importa qué
valor de xl g amos la pendiente va a ser
diferente así que si ustedes me dan un
valor x yo lo pongo en esta nueva
función aplico esta fórmula y les podré
decir cuál es la pendiente en ese punto
de x
y en el siguiente vídeo realizaremos un
ejemplo concreto para que todo esto
quede bastante más claro